by now almost everyone has heard about
berlin's disastrous
off-budget over-scheduled new airport
but few know the real story about what
went wrong
for years now i've been following the
saga of berlin brandenburg airport
international code ber
how could such incompetence and
corruption happen here
in germany a country famed for its
efficiency
why did it take berlin 12 years and more
than
six and a half billion euros ten times
the original budget
to finish this airport here's the full
story
of what went wrong at ber
when planners began working on the new
airport concept back in the 1990s
they drew up a list of seven possible
locations
politicians picked the bottom of the
list
schonefeld airfield 16 kilometers from
the city centre
a whole village had to be relocated to
make way for the new terminal
a district was constructed with hundreds
of homes for the displaced residents
at a cost of 80 million euros
elsewhere almost 10 percent of the
budget of the airport has been spent
noise-proofing homes under the flight
path
no night flights are allowed here and
there's no room for expansion
any of the other locations would have
been wiser
the architect who designed ber hates
airport shopping
meinhart von gurkan is the star
architect of berlin
he wrote a book in which he raged
against the multiplication
of airports most passengers have no
desire to buy anything
why should i have to drag around two
bottles of overpriced whiskey in a
plastic bag
like a beggar meinhard van gerken and
his partner
designed berlin's old much-loved tegel
airport back in the 1960s
four decades later they were
commissioned to build this new airport
but gurkhan purposely minimized the
number of shops
in ber modern airports need shops to pay
the bills
the plans had to be redrawn on the fly
to make room
for hundreds of extra duty-free shops
and cafes
nine months after construction had
started the city's politicians realized
the new airport
would be too small they ordered a
redesign
with 65 more floor space
the city's mayor demanded new boarding
gates
for the giant a380 aircraft
even though no airline had ever said
they wanted to bring the giant planes to
berlin
hundreds of significant changes were
made to the plans
but many of these significant changes
were made
after the main structure had already
been built
results-based building contracts were
torn up
contractors began charging by the hour
instead of by the job
ber became a bottomless money pit
smoke extractors sprinklers emergency
communications
all were designed for a much smaller
airport and they
failed crucial safety tests in 2012
just before the planned opening a review
found that ber was only
56 service ready
the proposed solution was called a human
machine
interface hundreds of workers were to
stand guard
around the clock to watch for fires and
operate emergency doors
politicians approved this plan they were
busy getting ready for
a grand opening party to be attended by
chancellor angela merkel
with a live tv coverage it took
one regional bureaucrat to stop the
nonsense
he refused to sign the crucial safety
certificate
with weeks to go the grand opening was
cancelled
ber was declared a failure
ber has been built twice the first time
badly
the second time slowly after the 2012
cancellation
more than 150 000 errors were found on
site
builders had to renovate a brand new
construction
thousands of kilometers of cables had to
be torn out and reinstalled
hundreds of fire safety walls were torn
down and rebuilt
lightning rods were installed for the
first time
builders said they spent much of their
time doing
nothing at all here's what one insider
had to tell us
if you want to do nothing it was
relatively easy
if you want to do a lot you could try in
the end
the plant changes again or
ber became a hotbed of criminality
workers were stealing material such as
copper
for instance many people were doing
business out of it
cutting cables and selling in the market
nobody's controlling you you can make an
extra salary
one manager took a bribe of half a
million euros
to hand out a contract another manager
was caught
taking 150 000 euros in cash in a
parking lot
from a company despite the
billions of euros wasted no one has ever
said
sorry for any of the mistakes berlin's
former mayor
klaus volvorite was head of the
supervisory board
during most of the disasters and ordered
many of the changes
he said it wasn't his fault reiner
schwartz was ceo
for many of the mistakes he was later
fired
but he sued and won a payout worth more
than a million euros
three other ceos followed only one has
managed
to finish the job after nine years of
construction
the new airport is finally opening
but some say the biggest disaster could
be yet to come
the coronavirus pandemic has cut air
traffic by 70 percent
and blown a huge hole in the budget
some fear that the airport company could
go bankrupt
so how did it all go so wrong after
years of covering the ber saga
i think the biggest mistake was the
unquestioning belief
in the myth of german efficiency nobody
noticed any of the problems
until it was too late few thought such
mismanagement was even possible here ber
now stands
as a monument to the mistake of
believing in myths
you